- [Narrator] The Gaza Strip
is a densely populated area
with more than 2 million
residents stretching
for 25 miles between Israel and Egypt.
But just underneath this
sprawling landscape,
another layer exists, a
vast labyrinth of tunnels.
The underground maze was
largely built by Hamas.
The group designated by the
US as a terrorist organization
controls the Palestinian enclave.
As Israel prepares for a
potential ground defensive
in the territory following a broad assault
by Hamas on October 7th,
the subterranean network
could play a key role.
So here's why experts say
these tunnels could make
urban combats costly for
both Israeli soldiers
and Palestinian civilians.
The underground network has
existed for decades inside Gaza.
Previously it was largely used
as a roots to smuggle goods
and weapons from Egypt into
the narrowest strip of land
that's twice the size of Washington DC.
But since then, the tunnels have evolved
to become a key military asset for Hamas.
- I went in 2014 with the
IDF into a Hamas built tunnel
during the conflict at that time,
and it was a pretty crazy
experience in a sense.
These were pretty sophisticated tunnels.
I'm about six foot, and
they were, you know,
I didn't have to bend down at all in them.
They were very well
reinforced with concrete.
There was communications
lines running down the side
of them, and then they also
had like, almost like a sort
of little rails or like a
sort of railway line running
along the length of the tunnel.
- [Narrator] During Israel's
seven week war on Gaza in 2014,
the Israel defense forces
or IDF said it destroyed 32 tunnels.
(bomb exploding)
They were used to hide
weapons, equipments and troops,
but also allowed Hamas militants
to launch surprise attacks
using cross-border underground networks.
In the years since then,
Hamas has continued
to develop its tunnel infrastructure,
and Israel has continued to target it.
This map, based on a
graphic shared by the IDF
represents networks of tunnels
that Israel said it damaged.
- I think the expectation is that there is
still a significant subterranean network
that Israel's gonna encounter if
and when it goes in into Gaza this time.
- [Narrator] Former Israeli
security officials say
Hamas has built hundreds of miles
of underground tunnels
in the last year or more.
Israel readying for a possible
ground invasion of Gaza
by carrying out airstrikes
targeting the subterranean network.
- I think that the Israeli,
the strategy will be to try
to destroy as much of the
tunnel network as possible
before they launch a ground invasion.
- [Narrator] However, the operation
to destroy them could be
challenging for Israeli forces.
One of the biggest
issues is locating them.
- Gaza is a dense urban environment
and being able to discern precisely
where a continuous tunnel,
which may in fact be deep
underground is located
as opposed to possibly natural pockets
of slightly differing geology,
or a host of other aspects
of the built up environment,
that's a really hard challenge.
- [Narrator] Even if a tunnel is located,
additional factors
including its depth can mean
precision bombs can
struggle to destroy it.
- It depends not only on knowing precisely
where the tunnel is beneath the surface,
but on having the
explosive power to be able
to damage a tunnel network that's beneath
perhaps layers of concrete,
possibly layers of metal,
whatever the built up
environment entails inherently,
as well as whatever materials
have gone into construction
of the tunnel itself.
And the net result is that tunnels are
relatively invulnerable in
many cases to air attack.
- [Narrator] And let's
say any Israeli operation
to destroy the Gaza tunnel
system could be complicated
by the presence of hostages.
Hamas' armed wing said in
the statements on Telegram
that some of them were being held
in the underground tunnels.
- If the aim is to rescue hostages,
they can't be detonating explosives
within the tunnel complex, which
might kill everyone inside.
It's going to require ground forces,
specifically tunneling forces who know how
to operate in these tight spaces,
who have trained extensively
in how to minimize the risk of ambushes
and how to avoid triggering
various booby traps.
- [Narrator] One 85-year-old
hostage who was released
by Hamas said she had been inside.
- There are a huge, huge network
of tunnels underneath, it
looks like a spider web.
- [Narrator] Entrances to the
subterranean passageways can
also be hidden within
residential infrastructure.
Experts say as a war continues any mission
to target the tunnels also
brings risks to civilians.